bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
pour suivre ces demi finales du
championnat du monde d'échecs féminin
2015 entre deux côtés pierre cramier la
suédoise face à natalia pogo 10 $ us et
de l'autre nous aurons maria musi tchouk
l'ukrainienne face à l'indienne harry
cadereau navali arica voilà alors on va
voir la partie entre pia cram ligne et
natalia pogo dit natalia pour une loi
qui nous a fait forte impression depuis
qu'elle a éliminés on l'a vu marie sebag
allait aussi revenu dans son match face
à que souza au il a fini par l'emporter
avec 2 notamment de gambie banco
extraordinairement bien jouer et donc
deux victoires avec les noirs alors
qu'elle était menée au score 1 ce qui
était tout à fait exceptionnelle comme
eux comme remonter comme mon résultat
alors on y va avec la suédoise pia
cramer qui est une légende du jeu
d'échecs depuis accra mines qui est né
en 1963 je crois bien donc qui a
beaucoup d'expérience face à nathalie
appros nina qui acquit à 30 ans qui
n'ont 85 et donc il y en a un peu moins
mais qui est bien entendu aussi un grand
mais de très bon niveau le niveau est à
peu près équivalent entre les deux
joueuses
avec peut-être avantage pour pia cramer
pour l'expérience mais on le voit une
super forme et pour natalia à pogo nina
capable du meilleur et notamment avec
les noirs donc on y va avec cabaye et f3
des cinq des quatre cavaliers m6 c4
alors voit déjà qu'on n'a pas de gambie
bien qu on a une grande dame classique
voilà aussi ce qu'avait laissé 3
cet objet 5,6 classique pour h 4 petit
rock et maintenant que trois à noter que
maintenant ça y est le gambit dame n'est
plus un gambit depuis ce qu'assure puis
on prend évidemment prendre du fou qu'a
lieu 4 propose anota à noter ici tout de
suite un échange des fous qu'il faut
changer si on veut pas perdre de temps
dans prend il à la prison le 4 est sans
doute possible quoique au gardon
cavaliers prend 2,4 ici tranquillement
belle et noir reprennent bien entendu du
pion qu'avaient les d2 qui attaquerait
le pire on voit là c'est une autre
variante et puis sans doute ici et noir
n'ont pas le choix il faut jouer très
certainement ici j'ai 5 voilà pardon f5
ici pour protéger le pion bon on a des
pions doublé là mais on a un fort centre
ici elle fait notamment un fort pions e4
peut-être on peut jouer avec la suite
peut-être avec 6,6 tour des huit pour
bien contrôler la casse des 5 et plus
tard on peut jouer ou 5 ça peut aussi
des doubles et les pions je sais pas
c'est une autre variante en tout cas
c'est possible donc après dun prendre
cette tour c'est un bon alors on prend
pas un 4 pourquoi pas ces 6 alors on a
dit l avantage on a déjà vu cette
variante un petit peu c'est la même idée
on voit très grande structure ici deux
chaînes de pions une chaîne ici une
chaîne là c'est très solide en dessin
mais le fou ou ses huit en compensation
et en fermer l on peut pas tout avoir
dams et 2 quelle était cette fois
le cavaly prend d'en prendre on évite de
doubler les pions puis on prend on prend
de la dame e5 alors clasico si on l'a vu
plusieurs fois notamment à les parties
avec marie ces vagues très vite
enfin ou assez vite avec le cavalier en
17 les noirs jouent tôt ou tard le cou
aux scènes libérateur ici la dame
justement été mis en scène ce qui permet
de contrôler cette case donc là tout et
tout est tenu et ça permet non seulement
de d'alléger la position au centre
puisque les blancs avaient un pion
s'entraînant à mériel donc on allège un
petit peu la position au centre et en
même temps on donne une diagonale enfin
pour ce fou voilà ce fou va pouvoir en
fait sortir voilà donc c'est un coup
libérateur classique 1 on le voit c'est
un thème dont on va voir cette partie
extrêmement de thématiques à tous les
niveaux e4 donc là ici on aurait pu au
choisir d'échanger mais pas des changes
donc maintenant il ya un pied noir en
quatre ans pions centre est un pion
blanc en d4
le centre est tenu par les deux joueuses
cavale et des deux voilà ça fait un peu
pression sur e4 tranquillement cabaye m6
dans lequel il si je protège 4
doublement et maintenant mon fou c'est 8
est libre de sortir
bon après ce qui va trouver une bonne
case c'est un autre problème
suffit pas de pouvoir sortir dame csn
propose un échange de dames
ici pas facile a refusé pas beaucoup de
coups intéressants
si on joue la dame en russie sont bouche
la sortie de son fonds bon donc on
échange pourquoi pas tout reprendre faut
six maintenant attention ça attaque le
pion à 2
donc 3,5 retour à 5 mais la tour sera en
protection 2 à 2 et puis un petit oeil
sur la clé la scène autour des 8 pouces
et 4 on va changer ce fou pourquoi pas
vous prend la vallée prend avec une
belle kazan 5 pour le cavalier mais les
noirs ont une belle case aussillon deux
des cinq a noté quant aux cinq qui
pourrait être chassés de toute façon pas
réussit alors à 6 pour les noix alors
l'idée de assis sans doute un c'est de
libérer à tours à huit qui va pouvoir
peut-être revenir vers le centre
maintenant cavalier b6 b8 tours 6e wife
8b quatre heures c'est l'heure alors ça
c'est le deuxième thème un navigant
bidart on a eu cette histoire là 2,5 qui
libérait pour les noirs bon maintenant
on est dans une finale puisque les dames
sur l'échangé de tours cavaliers que de
côté bien on a ici deux pions contre 3
alors cette attaque là quand on en a on
avance ses deux pions contre 3 qui est
souvent le souvent le cas dans le
candidat donc il faut connaître ce thème
parce qu'il est permanent
ça s'appelle l' attaque de minorité
alors si une minorité parce que j'ai que
deux pions contre 3 mais ces trois pions
son passif on voit bien qu'ils ont ne
peuvent pas bouger donc l'idée c'est
qu'on veut jouer à 4 et b5 casser cette
structure forcer les noirs à prendre et
la scala le pion bessette sera tout seul
donc probablement les blanches en feront
le siège et s'il arrive à le prendre
mais à la fin ils ont une finale avec un
pion de plus ici voilà il y aura
notamment un pion des 4 sera en plus
avec une finale avantageuse voilà donc
la tâche de minorités pas facile à
contrer un ce que les noirs sont un peu
passif dans cette ouverture tour des six
taureaux 5
dix huit tours c5 on n'échange pas on
estime que notre tour est plus active
que la tour e 8 ce qui n'est pas faux on
a une pression maximale notamment sur à
quatre baies 5 difficile pour les noirs
de faire autrement que de des changes et
donc d'affaiblir leur position tour de 8
à 4 6 h 3 on se presse pas pas baissé
tout de suite parce que sur pions prend
le pion c'est évidemment la tour attaque
le cavalier 3,8 g 4 on prend l'espace
aller loin voyons se pressent pas on
sait que tôt ou tard on va faire cette
manoeuvre cavalli prend alors ici est
les propositions des charges de
cavaliers bon pourquoi pas quelques
rames il n'hésite pas cavalier prend
tout reprend et là il change de tours
donc là pour me la joue cette variante
qui tentent de simplifier pourquoi pas
aller un peu sous pression les ailes et
passive à être obligés d'attendre là à
laisser d'échangé pour alléger la
pression mais après tour c5
alain problème ce pion des cinq est
définitivement faibles et pour le
protéger je suis obligé de jouer tôt des
six voilà alors c'est difficile pour les
noirs protéger des six il ya toujours
des poussées qui sont possibles ici bron
son passif mais bon c'est une finale
deux tours en plus où on l'a vu on en a
parlé c'est que c'est vrai que c'est
souvent nul difficile de gagner mais
comme tourne plus mais les blancs
continuent à 5 3 17
il a maintenant bessèges puis on prend
tout reprend donc ici la tour attaque bd
5 et attaquent aussi b5 faire quelque
chose 3 ces six échecs et on est obligé
de revenir en 17
et maintenant on active le roi gsm pour
les noirs alors est-ce que c'était
obligé sous pas forcément il ya rien qui
oblige et les noirs un jeu g5 c'est pas
forcément une bonne idée il faut
peut-être simplement attendre maintenant
c'est difficile toujours d'attendre
peut-être simplement attendre que les
blancs essaie de passer on a une
position passive mais normalement qui
doit pouvoir tenir bon g5 et pas pas
l'air mauvais une des idées de g5 ça
peut être justement d'empêcher le roi de
venir en h4 sans doute puis y en a cinq
pourquoi pas emna cdh 4g cinq ans est-ce
que jamais rien puisque sur les six
échecs ont simplement on prend le le
pion h61 donc on pourrait ici comme ça
avec le roi a pénétré sur ce côté là et
faire pression un petit peu sur ce côté
c'est possible mais si risqué parce que
la tour aussi pourrait venir
c'est difficile quand même la tour quand
même vis et à la défense du pion des 5
je pensais à tour f6 pour attaquer f2
mais peut-être quand même si on joue
j'ai 6 ans et christian piron peut-être
ces gens là main d'oeuvre est possible
bon en tout cas avec gsm qu'on empêche
sa bon le problème c'est qu'on affaiblit
un tout petit peu ses pions de l'ex-roi
bon alors c'est vrai que ça ne va pas
avec les langues comment passer un bon
moi j'ai trois quand même on évite la f3
f3 menace de prendre 1 4 et si les noirs
prennent et b tour 5 semble gagner est
un pion discutable parce que simplement
le pion à 5 aussi bas va tomber on ne
veut pas peut-être en retard on veut pas
lutter contre les pions sont trop d'eau
comprend tout simplement pourquoi pas
puis on prend et maintenant on voit 17
on attend les noirs sont obligés
d'attendre broyage et trois tours des
rois des huit voilà on a encore une
finale longue finale deux tours on en a
vu beaucoup dans ce championnat du monde
féminin notamment une victoire de
justement de marie marie sebag face à
pour une idée de la première une finale
deux tours avec un piège classique donc
c'est pas parce qu'il a joué six finales
deux tours on dit que c'est souvent nul
mais c'est très très difficile à jouer 3
217 roi de deux des huit roi des deux
ans les sept rois des trois peut-être
maintenant pour jouer que quatre en huit
et non on revient au dehors regardé
comme pierre cramier ne se pressent pas
ça c'est l'expérience qui parle
elle manner pour avoir bon peut-être que
les normes vont faire une faute on sait
jamais roy 17 non les noirs attendre
bref un bon 8 rue des huit tours elle
souligne par ces coups là et la suite
des coups elle souligne le fait que les
noirs sont dans une position extrêmement
passive
moi j'ai deux points 17
en 24 mois des 8es maintenant h4 alors
voilà donc h4 propose une rupture qui
n'aurait pas été possible si le pion
était resté angers7
c'est toujours toujours responsable
comme ça de pousser ses pions
mais bon on l'a vu il y avait des
manoeuvres aussi de roy possible
infiltration qu'est ce qu'il fallait
faire donc là on pourrait prendre h4
c'est envisageable et jouèrent 17
attendre puisque finalement cette tour
est très très bien placé c'est pas
facile pour les blancs de progresser la
tour protège à 6 elle protège des scènes
qu est le roi peut toujours soit protégé
bessette soit éventuellement même f7 bon
et le roi blanc on voit pas trop comment
ils pourraient pénétrer dans le camp et
si la tour blanche où on pourrait
s'activer en attaquant les pions avec le
donc ça semble tenir on pourrait prendre
h théâtre mêlant ne prennent pas ce jour
17 et h5
alors ça commence à et commence à voir
des thèmes parce que la hache 5
bon on a un pion ici h&m bien protégé
par g4 ce pion h6 s'il tombe on a un
pion passe équipe usée il est protégé
par g4 ça c'est un premier un premier
point est bon et ce qui serait assez
près d'am aussi il a plus que 3 contres
alors qu'a contrario celui là il est à
un deux trois quatre coups de faire
d'amis comme une différence de qualité
entre ses deux pions bon tout de suite
on voit pas comment passer mais on va
voir qu'il va se passer des choses
deuxième point important je pense ou si
c'est que ces deux pions dominent les 3
et wii domine ces trois pions puisqu'on
peut pas jouer et cinq sur f5 puis on
prend le 20e puis on est donc c'est un
problème parce que quand on a deux pions
qu'il en domine 3 ça veut dire que après
eux quatre éliminations du pion des
scènes on a un pion passé au centre on
joue virtuellement à l'exception de plus
n'a pas vraiment un pion de plus de ce
qu'il ya bien ils étaient de purs mais
le fait qu'on domine trois pions avec
deux nous donne quand même une liberté
de jouer pour le gain avec un pion libre
en des huit en f3 3,17
3e 2 on se presse pas avalé huit 3d
prend 3,17 tomber cinq attaques c7 et le
4 tailles arrive à pierre kravis
évidemment ils doivent jouer pour le
gall on le voit les noirs ce sont eux
qui ont la position passive
les blancs ont une position active forte
puis on prend reprend et os 6 alors ça a
l'air bon menace tour f4 prend ici j'ai
quatre tours f5 échec
trois des cinq et f cette emprise tour
échec en c4 est maintenant f6 voilà pas
facile là ici de jouer autre chose que
f6 si ce n'est un coup passif du type
tour 17 epci sur la protégeant m6 par
par la tour voyez comme ses deux pions
dominé les trois et que finalement c'est
comme si presque comme si on avait un
pion de plus en plus
puis on passait donc l'avantagé est aux
mains des blancs après cette longue
manoeuvre mais noir on ont pu jouer que
passivement aura des cinq tours 3 il
faut absolument empêcher le roi de venir
attaquer alors est ce que les noirs
auraient pu jouer autre chose si sans
doute oui un coup comme tout raciste est
possible mais dans ce cas-là roy e 4 et
6 tours échec maintenant wife 5 ils
s'allieront va pénétrer en j-6 on va
prendre h6 et on l'a dit ce pion il va
vite adam voyez c'est le problème de
cette manne peut-être il fallait prendre
h4 ou ne pas jouer j'ai celle qu on
s'est créé une faiblesse ici une petite
faiblesse qui nous oblige là on va jouer
des tours aux trois alors on va essayer
avec les noirs de ce danger sur ce pion
ce que là on va on va perdre du matériel
après le coup suivant des blancs la
tourbe et 6 très bien joué blum blum et
noir vont pouvoir se venger après tour
ici voilà roi maintenant ça y est achi
s'est perdu
tous rêvent 4 on va 6,2 selon lui sur
les pions on donne pas le pion passé
centrale tour échec reprend tout reprend
échec avec le pion regardez comme la
tour ici bien protégé par son pion on
oblige le roi noir à partir en plus
bessette est en prise donc voilà roy
s'est vite à la fois je contrôle la
poussée du pion des et en même temps je
garde un oeil sur bessette
mais c'est tout ça est encore très
passif roger 6 et c'est ce qu'on a dit
tour g1 roi prend celui-là il est plus
proche de dames que celui là et en plus
le roi noir est bloquée contre le
deuxième pion passé ça sent le roussi g4
roger 7 g 3 h 6 on n'a pas le choix
maintenant regarder si on joue dès 2 h 7
et on fera un monsieur pu tenter quand
même alors on regarde ce qui se passe
quand même sur g2
ah oui très simplement très fort tour b2
et voilà c'est fini
si la tour bouge je prends le pion g2
tout simplement voilà et là je menace h
7 h 8 et le roi protège si tu auras cher
je prends des jeux projet de six tours 6
tours d1 on va voir que ça marche pas
non plus tour d il faut prendre j'ai
deux parce que sinon je perds le pion
fascinant je fais d'un pardon donc ici
pour prendre des six là mais simplement
on pousse et les noirs peuvent rien
faire il n'y a pas d'échec perpétuelle
puisque sur échec simplement rouages 6
et sur échec maintenant regarder très
simplement tout rejet 6 terminé dame est
imparable tour des huit tours g8 et
c'est fini maintenant si on fait des
échecs on peut pas s'y connaît en échec
voilà la torre cloud est donc là c'est
fini la partie finie donc h6 tourache un
contrôle le pion menace g2 dont moi la
tour b 2 voilà je contrôle la casse g2
donc je domine ce pion torts h 4 h 6
échecs m6 menace de faire h 8 dames tour
h théâtre roger 6 3d cet échec on
reprend tour b 1
hall 5 à 6
j'ai deux
donc j'ai un c'est fini ce pion est
perdu et maintenant sur échec parce que
sinon on fait à sept à huit
et bien simplement rush 5 et c'est
terminé la dame est la dame est
imparable si on joue six tours j'ai 3
ici par exemple
simplement on fait pas d'âme parce que
sinon on se prendrait tourache trois
échecs
et puis on prend non simplement ici on
joue
ainsi on peut faire il ya dame échec
voilà mais sinon joueurs aux athlètes ça
marche aussi dans la roche plate sinon
il ya d'un échec ici et ça marche aussi
mais roanne 4 marche aussi la dame
regarder la tour ici peut pas maintenir
en n3 voilà donc belle victoire depuis
accra ming très technique dans une
finale deux tours pas évidente à jouer
elle a patiemment attendu son heure les
noces sont a fait bien peu tout seul en
jouant g5y n'ont pas pris h4 bon il
aurait pu simplement patienter au
maximum et au final que nina est menée
simplement bon à l'oral et blanc quand
même dans la deuxième on peut espérer
revenir mais avantage appli akram ling
et dans l'autre demi finale donc arica
et musi tchouk ont fait match nul et
arica orale et blanc dans la deuxième
partie avant les éventuelles tie-break
pour savoir donc qui sera en finale qui
sera en position de remporter le titre
de championne du monde d'échecs 2015
voilà merci de nous avoir suivi sur des
modèles tv je me rendez vous pour la
suite de ces demi-finales au revoir